one of the most unique spots in las
vegas to grab a beer a picture this
taking a sip out of the patio
overlooking the bellagio fountains it
doesn't really get much better than that
especially with a nice ipa
here's christian kosovo's with more on
this destination that promises to be a
one of a kind experience
[Music]
i haven't tried this one actually but
good great views and great brews here at
the beer park
at the paris it's great it's actually
your first time and
look at the nachos the burger about to
try this but this is really good
the 19 000 square foot second level spot
opened in 2016
but it's pouring much more than beer
host pandemic
we're all about experience here so if
you have a great experience that's
different than anywhere else on the
strip
i think we've won the name itself
attracts thousands to explore its
variety of beers
but the food according to this group we
got the
brisket grilled cheese and the chicken
cheese steak
with misters and fans to cool you off
this trendy venue is filled with giant
tvs
and even has an indoor lounge with a
variety of games
just a sample of why they were voted
best rooftop bar
by thrillist i think it's great i
haven't seen the water show in so long
so right now when it came on i didn't
even realize we were just across the
street from it so that was a great
surprise
[Applause]
christian casarez 8 news now the beer
park director tells us during the day
the venue geared towards families
at night the energy is a lot stronger
you get to add it to your list to check
out it's a great spot
did a new year's eve show there a couple
years ago and we're just talking about
it's a lot of fun
and a wide variety of beer selection